praise and gentlemen Rick crashing
Thank You president Coleman that was
really very sweet very wonderful uh you
know as president was talking about the
wean hall i was reminded of the the
first immigration course where i had to
stand up as a young faculty member you
know and talk about my research for the
for the graduate students to try to
convince them to work for me or with me
uh you know during that coming become a
year and and of course that was back in
wean hall in the one of those wonderful
cinderblock classrooms that we had
there's probably 50 409 and and i look
at this room and I say wow it thinks it
really gotten better you know the the
unlikely sequence of events that brought
me to Carnegie Mellon back in nineteen
seventy-nine so it's 30 years ago
exactly this year that unlikely sequence
of events you could probably best be
described as fate I was a graduate
student at the University of Rochester
and and we were very lucky there that we
were the first place outside of xeroxed
have access to Xerox Altos and the three
megabit experimental ethernet know back
in the mid you know too late 1970s and
so I developed a series of skills
associated with building systems you
know distributed systems and using local
area networks and using Altos as it so
happened as the story was told to me
Roger Eddie was at an event with Jerry
Feldman who had started the department
at the University of Rochester and we
serve asking do you have any good
students that are graduating that they
have some of these skills and I said
well yes actually I do does this Rick
ration and Eugene ball and and so I was
just coming back from my interview loop
looking for a job and I was starting to
think about you know which of the places
I visited none of which were CMU which
of the places I visited were were the
one type
I wanted to think more about it and
choose and I got this call from Raj you
know trying to convince me to come up to
Carnegie Mellon which I really haven't
thought much about it all before that
and yet they had this this great project
they wanted to start called the spice
project scientific personal integrated
computing environment it's my first
introduction to really long acronyms and
and so so i drove i drove down i met up
with raj you know he took me around on a
whirlwind tour yog met with Scott
Fullman and and I think Howard I think
you were on the loop for that and number
of other people and it was it it was
fairly clear to me that they that that
this was an unusual is doing something
unusual i was kind of snuck in through
the system i'm not sure exactly how that
worked but but needless to say you know
they made me an offer they I got really
excited about the prospects of coming to
the Carnegie Mellon and frankly I think
the thing that got me the most excited
about the prospects of coming here was
the audacity of the department in terms
of what it was willing to undertake the
the vision behind some of the projects
of department had done you know co MP CM
star and and what they wanted to do with
with spies was just you know it was
tremendous it was they really wanted to
change you know what personal computing
was going to be like in a scientific
academic setting and and that really
appealed to me and the idea that you
could you could really make an enormous
difference you could take on a really
large project and I felt that same you
was the kind of place that was willing
to do it but even even more important to
me as I came here wasn't just the
audacity of what the department was
willing to undertake the risk that it
was willing to take to advance science
but it was also the trust that existed
between the members of this community I
mean people I really felt that people
cared about each other in the department
whether they were in your area
or not they were willing to invest even
in a young new research scientist coming
from from a small computer science
department they were willing to invest a
lot of trust in me too you'll come in
you know build a distributed computing
environment around local area networking
you know training of a student trained
staff and then build an operating system
for this new scientific personal
computing environment you know and it
and the fact that there was that trust
the fact that you felt that the faculty
and the students you're really believed
in each other and we're willing to trust
each other to work together to
accomplish a large goal in some sense I
think made it possible for me and the
others that were involved to do more
than we probably would have been able to
do any other way we felt a
responsibility to live up to that trust
and I think that was a critical part of
the success of certainly my early career
here now a president cone mentioned this
link article and you know I don't really
know when this picture was taken exactly
it pretty much had to be taken like the
first year I was here because it has the
concept terminal for those who remember
the old concept terminals and the it
really was a you know that's it that's
the old office i was in i think was down
answer than the bowels of wean hall and
the good news is i didn't really have to
spend much time in that office because i
found one of the other nice aspects of
the old wean hall was that it was such a
labyrinth there were rooms that no one
had ever found before and there was this
and Howard remembers this there is a
hard whack late there's there's this
service secret room in the in the
machine room area that for some reason
Knowlton seem to have ever used for
anything so I moved one of the Altos
into that room and it was my secret
place that I could go and work and
one even knew that I was there for a
young faculty member having a place you
can escape is actually a really good
thing I got a lot of programming done in
that location now the geeky look thing
has come back you know so sadly 30 years
ago was it really in style you know
after after just a few years at Carnegie
Mellon I was looking a lot better you
know I found a barber and that's an old
Mike but thats a macro vac so this has
probably been about the you know mid 80s
because I would guess there abouts I
still have those weird dinosaur things
during my house in Seattle and probably
still have some of the books and
magazines and things that are on that
shelf i don't really throw a whole lot
away which and i just wanted to just say
what at Carnegie Mellon really mean to
me yo this is the before and this is the
after okay yeah kid I that's that's
that's all I can really say now the
obviously one of the major things I did
when I was here working with a lot of
great yellow faculty and students a
number of whom are in this audience was
to really take the ideas from a system I
done as a graduate student at the
University of Rochester called rig for
Rochester intelligent gateway and and
and to rethink those ideas in the
context of the sort of new era of
personal computing and that is when I
developed something called the the
accent operating system and and then
that led directly that was really
designed for the perks for those people
that River the perks the three worst
corporation perks the that was really
then led directly to in a few years the
development of the mock operating system
which has really become much more famous
than any of the previous one what I
think was really interesting it again I
think that it was the environment here
at Carnegie Mellon that really allowed
this to happen is that you know
approach that that was taken with these
systems was one of really you know
having a fundamental set of abstractions
upon which you could build a larger
operating system environment typically
in the operating system space people
don't worry so much about the the serve
basic abstractions of the operating
system they'd sort of say well what can
I do at this level that supports the
level above that and how do I fit the
pieces together you know mock and well
accent and mock were really attempts at
saying if if I come up with a very
fundamental set of mechanisms and
abstractions can I then build everything
from that you know and even more so you
know can I even think about building it
itself from those same abstractions so I
can I make this completely recursive
intellectually and so that was one of
the things I think that really
distinguished mock and accent from the
systems that came before it but also I
think it's it's a statement about you
know the the notion that it was
important to try to create something
that was intellectually elegant and that
made sense and that this was an
environment which one could actually do
that and not be sort of put in a in a
box and said well no you really can't do
it quite that way you've got to do it
some other way instead so I felt really
good about that you know in terms of
some of the key elements of these
systems we won think people often refer
to and you see it you'll see it in some
of the chapters and various operating
system books that talk about mock the
people refer to the term microkernel but
generally speaking most people don't
really remember what it actually meant
in the original accent work the many of
the underlying operating system / if ms
primitives were actually implemented in
microcode in fact when we started the
spice project as Raj well remembers you
know we we felt that you had to have
microcode in the machine in order to be
able to achieve the performance that we
were looking for and so that's where the
term microcurrent will really came from
but most people misinterpreted that is
meeting small kernel and so today more
often than not people say well gee it
wasn't that small and and they're right
but it but again it was a different
different term the you know the notion
of machine independence and support for
different kinds
of architectures my sister's name is new
promote by the way yeah I invented these
terms in my office and the seventh floor
of weed hall because i couldn't none of
the other faculty members knew the you
know had good names for those
architectures and so I said okay well
this will be like you know they're
actually sort of was a good name for
Yuma this a uniform memory access
architecture Numa we serve non-uniform
memory access architectures that wasn't
really good name for that and that names
really stuck and Norma was sort of the
distributed no remote memory access
architecture so those are the this name
stuck the other two really didn't but at
least i got my sister's name in there so
you know you can't can't can't do too
bad but i think again the key thing that
keep idea behind mark was this notion
that you could build a system out of a
small set of basic abstraction you could
layer number of things around out you
could put it on a wide variety of
different machine and then you could
support different kinds of operating
systems on top of that now i'm going to
i found an old video I'm going to show
so in this basically I'm trying to do
this is an old video I found just lying
around i had to transcribed into in a
digital form sorry it's not very clear
anymore but it's an old VHS tape this is
mock running on a next machine so in
1986 Steve Jobs and and and next decided
to use mock as the basis for the next
computer and so they took the mock
colonel at that point of used as the
basis for their next step operating
system and this is just showing off the
fact that it's running and it was cool
it look really interesting again that's
more like 1986 this is mock running on a
micro box so yet a completely different
architecture like a complete different
system you know and this now is see if
it pops up here this is mock running on
a Macintosh back this would probably
been about 1988
I'm guessing 1987 and again what was
interesting about this was just that we
could do it and that we were able then
to layer the entire Mac OS operating
system on top of that and run it so all
on all this little video is doing is
just showing that that it actually
worked you know which is really a lot of
what you show when you do operating
system presentations there's a really a
whole lot else to show so you know I
think I just want to skip over to
something here all this is trying to
show that it actually worked it actually
worked pretty well then in fact this is
a you know dark castle running on a mac
and mac OS running on top of mock you
know on him on a macintosh so gives you
a sense of the fact that it was it was
working and then lastly here if I skip
forward a bit this is this is mock
running on a an old pc this is an old
luggable you know plasma you know orange
plasma display pc and guinea you can see
kind of the other that yes it does in
fact work so the fact that mock could be
moved to so many architectures you know
gave it in in many ways both of you know
a lot more longevity and have allowed it
have a greater influence that might
otherwise have had many of you know that
the current version of the mac OS
actually i just pulled this off of
Wikipedia the current version mac OS
actually sits on top of the of the mach3
point Oh Colonel that was developed here
and so if you have a Mac or if you have
an iPhone you're actually running code
that I and my graduate students were
writing back in 1983 and if you were to
ask me in 1983 do you realize or just
told me do you realize that someday the
code that you're writing would run on a
cell phone you know i would say what's a
cell phone
which is another way of saying you know
software can actually have a much longer
life than you ever really intended and
often winds up showing up on devices you
never imagined it would show up on and
who knows what will happen I mean today
there are versions of UNIX that are
based on moc moc was the first 64-bit
version of Unix so there are a lot of
implementations based on that Mauch was
part of a central you know business
competition between IBM and and AT&T and
sun and digital and a bunch of other
companies you know back in the 1980s you
know we got used as a as weaponry in
that battle and as a result again you
know things you know the mock became
digital UNIX it became the basis for
compacts unix and and for after the
acquisition HPS tru64 unix so it's heard
had a life in many different forms
probably very few people know this but
in fact accented mock also we're both
part of the reason I wound up at
Microsoft but also they led in some
sense to Microsoft making the investment
in what became windows NT because there
was an early project in the mid nineteen
eighty six time frame at Microsoft where
they actually took accent they actually
had perks at Microsoft they're running
accent they took mark they ran it on on
boxes and it was a it was the
inspiration for making the investment
that became the windows NT investment
you know bringing Dave Cutler building
that whole that whole environment so so
in some sense we have been able to have
an influence on a number of different
systems whether it's pcs unix system or
Macintosh systems over time now I
mentioned you know there was an unlikely
sequence of events that got me to Mike
to Carnegie Mellon there was an equally
unlikely sequence of events that got me
to Microsoft in 1991 Gordon bell who's
in the audience probably remembers that
he called me at home at dinnertime fact
the probably
would have been about march or april of
nineteen ninety one and you know these
you know when people call you at dinner
time you know your first assumption is
you know they're trying to sell you
something yeah which was true he was
trying to sell me something but but but
you have to understand he it was Gordon
bail right so I had to take the phone
call so I got up from the dinner table I
went up to the third floor of my my
place in shadyside and i took this phone
call from gordon because you know you
just can't hang up on Gordon Bell ok and
I'm sure he was counting on that and
Gordon had been it was working with
Nathan Myhrvold at Microsoft looking for
someone to become director of the new
research lab that they wanted to create
and mostly I was very polite and said no
but Gordon convinced me to at least have
him and Nathan show up in my office you
know a few weeks later and Gordon
remembers all those very well and and
and talk to me there right so again I
was very polite you know they showed up
I was very nice to them and and I said
well you know I'm not really interested
in doing anything like this but you know
Microsoft mean back when you know in
those days Microsoft was an awfully
small company compared to what it would
be what it is today and it wasn't really
clear to me that they were really
serious about doing basic research but
they prevailed upon me to actually go
visit Microsoft so kind of you know
keeping the whole thing going this is
part of how you negotiate with someone
and so we so I went to Microsoft and you
know and I came back and in some sense I
still said no I came back and said no
but but I also came back with the sense
of you know this is a company much like
Carnegie Mellon that had an audacity to
dream about things that could be done
that in some sense seemed crazy of it
yet there was an energy there was an
excitement there was a belief in what
you could do and what you accomplished
and and the feeling that there was that
same kind of trust I mean every every
executive I spoke to on that visit you
know had clearly read research papers
they were
involved in the field they understood
the meaning of doing basic research and
and so you know that kind of weight am I
thinking and eventually and I won't go
with all the details of how I made the
decision but eventually I decided to go
to Microsoft my official decision was on
September first of 1991 that's how we
date the beginning of Microsoft Research
and we've just had our 18th anniversary
and and I when I started microsoft
research I would have been really happy
you know getting to 100 150 people
having a great little research lab I in
at no point would I have envisioned that
we would have gotten to where we are
today and today we have over 850 PhD
researchers working in six different
locations around the world of many of
the people that I knew back in those
days as a faculty member now work for me
including Gordon and you know and again
you know the we have more members of the
National Academy of Engineering than
most universities last time I checked we
had more than the University of
Washington we have you know some of the
you know the most interesting most
exciting researchers and many different
research areas and that's again you know
the growth of the organization is
something I really wouldn't have
imagined my view of microsoft research
was really based on my experiences at
Carnegie Mellon and the mission
statement you know for microsoft
research could have just as easily
except for the Microsoft card could just
as easily been a mission statement for
Carnegie Mellon and the key thing was
moved to state-of-the-art forward and
then when you had great ideas get them
into practice make something happen
change the world with what you do and
that's been our mission statement for 18
years I've had the luxury I think of
being one of the longest sitting you
know heads of a major research lab ever
so I've had the opportunity to keep that
mission in the focus for that that
period of time it was very much a CMU
style organization and I the way I think
of that is that you know we really built
around the con
except of critical mass groups we
brought in senior people to create new
areas we had a reasonable person
principle we really believed in people
we didn't we didn't put a lot of
bureaucracy in their way we we don't we
didn't and don't have budgets for
research projects that was true pretty
much for CMU back in the 80s it's a
little hard to do that now the GAO is a
little bit more excited than it used to
be but the but a Microsoft I can do that
right and so I can I can I can have that
sort of sense of collegiality within the
organization where no one has to worry
about you know if I if I do something
good you know will I get more resources
or if someone else does something good
and I help them will they get more and I
get less you know I can have that kind
of an atmosphere so I mean had these are
really key I think this part 2 goes back
to what I was saying earlier about the
my experience when I was at CMU feeling
that I was mentored very well the people
people gave me great advice Raj gave me
great advice Alan Newell gave me great
advice Nico habermann gave me great
great advice you know I was mentored
very well I was I was trusted to make
things happen and I think that's
something that I feel is important in
our organization as well and something
I've tried to preserve we tried we tried
to keep a flat model it's hard now the
organization is 1500 people in it it's
hard to keep a very completely flat
organization but we try to keep it as
flat as we can we're very aggressive
about being part of the academic
community and doing peer reviewed
research that's critical to our success
and we really believe in bringing in a
lot of outside people from university
environment and giving back to the
university community and over the
history of microsoft research more than
fifteen percent of all the money I've
been given by the company to do basic
research has gone directly to
universities I think that's a huge
number when you think about you know
what that actually means over the years
the we have the largest PhD intern
program in the world and and really the
during the summers I believe we're the
largest academic computer science
organization the world we have 850
faculty and a thousand PhD students so
it's just a new
this opportunity for us to work with all
those students but I think it's also
incredibly valuable for the students not
just because they get to work with with
great people that we have but also
frankly because they get to know each
other and they get to learn from each
other and they build relationships that
are going to last a lifetime because
those are the people that are going to
be the professors and the research
scientist sort of the future I always
loved slides like this because it's one
of the few things I can do with
Microsoft where I can talk about market
share just the same way as my colleagues
in the product rooms you know we have
great market share of basic research I
this is really an old slide that's why
everything says 2008 but the last night
I threw in the SOS p result because SSDs
just next month it in big sky montana
and will have almost a third of all the
papers will have microsoft author there
and that's that's a really great result
and i think from my perspective this is
just a statement about how much we care
about publication how much we care about
you know being part of that environment
now I sometimes I feel a little bit like
a voice in the wilderness you know
within the the industrial research world
you know arguing for really unfettered
basic research because that's what we do
and that's what we believe in and that
comes from my experiences the Carnegie
Mellon and the environment that existed
here now you know a lot of people
misunderstand you know why you do basic
research you know they serve look at the
great work coming out of CMU we're
coming out of MIT or coming out stand
for even coming out of us and they'll
say wow that's fabulous you know that
means you know more patents that means
great technology that they can go into
our products or new products you know
that means you're going to have all
these smart people to fix problems you
know it means we're going to be able to
know what's going to happen in the
future and they can target our company
round out and and those things are all
consequences of having a great research
organization you know their consequences
I mean that's those are some of the
things that come out of Carnegie Mellon
in a great environment that you have
here
there are things that come out of our
group but people will look at that
especially business people people in the
industrial research in the dust real
world and they'll say great I want that
that's what I want from you and so can
we can you just do more of those things
ok because i want the output of the
research organization and they start to
think about managing research using this
as their desired output goal and an
industrial environment when you manage
research to get a specific result
inevitably you get left right there was
a I'm not going to pick on on Google too
much but there's a conversation one of
our researchers Eric orbits had he was
introduced to Larry Page at a conference
in 2008 and rather than Larry saying hi
how are you even being polite he said
you do it all wrong and and eric said
okay what do you mean he said well the
right way of doing research is you have
researchers embedded with product people
you know they all have to be working
together and it's a paraphrase so don't
quote me exactly and you know there are
a lot of people that believe that and
that is actually a perfectly fine way of
doing technology transfer I mean there's
nothing wrong with that idea it's a
great way of getting technology transfer
but at the end of the day it's it's you
know like killing the goose that laid
the golden a right you probably will
find another golden egg inside the goose
you may even find two if it's prolific
that's all you're getting then you need
a good new goose right and I think
that's the problem is when people think
about research in terms of only the
output they don't realize what research
is really for and I think you know in my
philosophy you know this is what
research is for its for making sure
you're still around you know making sure
that you survived whether the you as a
company whether the you as a society or
a country it's making sure that you've
made
intellectual investments that will let
you change rapidly if there's in the in
the words of a navire bush if there's a
war if there's a disease if there's
famine or in the case of a company if
there's a new competitor a new business
model or a new technology you know those
are the things that I think are really
important and that's sort of that's
that's our belief system and my belief
system and I really that's our came and
from my experiences here at CMU now a
building like this and a time like this
in some sense is all about the future
okay it's about the next generation and
this is our my next generation you've
met a couple of them already there's my
two youngest boys my son Danny was a
graduate student here for a couple of
years getting his master's degree now he
just started a job in manhattan new york
city getting a really nice salary thank
you thank you seeing you you know this
my oldest son Faris who many of you
remember walking the halls and you have
with a screwdriver and trying to unscrew
the panels off of perks and my daughter
Keira who is now a undergraduates at the
University of Washington doing some
interesting work in Arabic studies but I
wanted to show you this picture as the
very last thing I'll show you this is my
son tiran he's at his laptop he's
programming in visual studio two
thousand and agency sharp and this is
something his mother my wife Terry
taught him and and it gives you a sense
of you know what you know what the
future might hold you know 30 years from
now you know maybe he will be you know
in this auditorium of lecturing or maybe
it'll be one of your children or maybe
it'll be one of grandchildren but that's
why we make these kinds of investments
you know these kinds of investments in
basic research and the research are
really about the future thank you very
much
you